good evening members
officers public
press i think there might be some um
welcome to this extraordinary fall
council meeting on wednesday the 30th of
june
2021. my name is councillor carly mays
and i am the vice chairman of the
malden district council there are a few
housekeeping rules
um and issues just to run through the
set up of the meeting has been
uh designed to mitigate for covid and we
ask members to work to the protocols
agreed at the council meeting on the
29th of april
2021 in the interest of member and
officer safety
that is to wear a mask unless you are
exempt
during the meeting and when using any of
our facilities here
to remain seated when speaking although
uh using a visor so as to not to be
heard properly
and use sanitizing gel when and whenever
appropriate
please help us to keep everybody safe
and well officers members and
public and press this meeting will be
streamed live
and recorded and by being present you
are consenting to being recorded
the process this evening will be as
follows during each item
please hold up your indicator on the
desk in front of you
to show that you like you would like to
speak i will then invite you to speak
your contributions should be clear and
concise as possible
referring to agenda papers with an
appropriate reference and paragraph
number please remain
seated swapping your mask for a visor
finally can i ask members please to wait
for the microphone to reach you
before speaking this is to ensure that
everybody here
can hear you but also that the public on
the live feed
can hear you thank you
tara could i have um the apologies
please
that's what i've got on my list thank
you
we now move to declarations of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the needs arise
through the meeting
counsellor nunn
yes madam chair um i'm an essex county
councillor
and we are agnes county councillor
consulted at certain items
uh but i've got no cleaner or
non-procurement interests as i see at
the moment
thankfully uh councillor dharam
yes thank you councillor morris we do
have and as we get going
into items of business that um
microphone will come
directly to the member that wishes to
speak
councillor stevens
thank you councillor jarvis
thank you any other interests
thank you um we'll now move on um oh
no i need to declare a non-pecuniary
interest in
item 17.
we now move on to item four it is
recommended that the minutes of the
statutory annual council meeting held on
the 20th of may
2021 found on pages 5
to 20 are approved as a true and
accurate record
these are presented for accuracy only i
so do iso move do i have a seconder
thank you councillors none if any member
wishes to raise any matters of accuracy
uh can they do so now uh i can
cancel a channel
as much as he might be a handsome swan i
think it should say
councillor swain um
so uh i just thought i'd mention that i
meant to email you but i
do apologize i i went to my head thank
you
thank you that's okay
thank you councillor channel thank you
council channel
um can these be agreed by sent
agreed oh i beg your pardon councillor
shawnee
can you wait for the microphone uh
counselor sean asley
[Music]
um page nine um chairman please um i'm
down as
rgf rather than ngf just a minor
thing but thank you thank you very much
uh can these be agreed by ascent
item five public questions um which
there are none
so we'll move swiftly on to uh
chairman's announcements
um i've got two announcements um i
attended a lovely
uh service at chelmsford cathedral
uh it was an even song it was all a
little bit different no singing i got
very hot in my mask
but it was an absolutely lovely evening
so i just thought i'd share that with
you
secondly a bit of housekeeping really
i'd like to remind members that they
need to leave if they wish to leave the
meeting
could they please make that known rather
than just get up and walk out
thank you
we now move to item seven the minute
book
i call upon councillor mrs stilts
uh to present these minutes councillor
mrs stilts
thank you madam chair i present to you
the minutes of the performance
governance and audit committee
on the 10th held on the 10th of june
2021
these are for noting and accuracy only
they are found on pages 21 to 30.
i so move can i have a seconder
thank you i give you page 21
page 22 age 23
page 24 page 25.
page 26 page 27
age 28 age 29
and page 30. thank you madam chair can
we agree these by
a cent please thank you
thank you um we now move on to
um i call upon councillor siddall to
present the minutes number 102
information technology uh councillor
siddal
thank you chairman i present the minutes
of strategy resources committee
meeting held on the 15th of june
2021 found on pages 31
to 46 and propose their reception
and adoption with the exception of
minute number 102
information communication technology
strategy 21-26
found on page 32 of the report the
recommendation is that the holden
district council
ict strategy 2126
attached at appendix 1 to these minutes
found on page 37.
for distribution to all staff giving
support and guidance
to management on future ict projects
and planning be agreed can i have a
seconder for that please
our councillor um swain
uh can i have a move that recommendation
by ascent agreed
thank you so therefore on i
moved the minutes on pages 31
32 33 34
35 36 37
38 39 40
41 at least it's not hundreds
43 44 45 and 46.
are they agreed council agreed
thank you i say move
thank you members um we now move to item
eight on your agendas and this is the
minute of the meetings of the council
uh these are for noting only do i have a
secondar
thank you councillor none can these be
agreed by ascent
thank you members
uh item nine statement from the leader
we now move to this and
i give you the leader of the council
councillor mrs stamp
thank you chairman thank you members
officers
members of the public and press the
cancelled by-elections
in may this year consolidated the
position of the independent group
as the largest group on malden district
council
we are now established as the
administration of the council
and are looking to bring stability a
reward
a renewed focus on service delivery and
corporate plans and projects
to the residents and businesses of the
district
i want to start by remembering the
residents business owners
friends family and loved ones that have
suffered loss
due to the covid19 pandemic and to be
mindful of those who are still
struggling with the excitement anxieties
and challenges
that the coronavirus has brought to
everyday lives
right now livelihoods and health are my
main concerns
including mental health residents need a
council that is understanding
engages more and takes positive action
that puts our homes and our future
firmly at the centre of all our
decisions
conversations and policies the council
office
continues to operate as a vital nhs
resource
providing vaccines to protect our
residents
and to help us regain our confidence and
freedoms
i want to praise all the nhs staff key
workers
and volunteers for their tireless hard
work and thank them for the care
they have given and continue to from
crisis comes opportunity
and there is a definite sense of hope
and community
but this comes with an understandable
cautiousness
about what we still don't know of the
pandemic
and what and of what a potential third
wave might bring
the longer term impacts from the
pandemic are not
yet fully known national data is
starting to show us
that in the modern district women were
furloughed more than men
and that retail leisure and tourism have
been hit
the hardest there are also concerns for
the construction industry
as access to skilled workers and
materials is challenging
this adds to the current current cost of
living
so the need to safely welcome back
visitors to our beautiful district
and supporting our local businesses is
paramount for our future success
like many public sector organizations
and businesses
the council's finances remain
challenging the pandemic has seen an
increased demand for council services
yet income from sources such as parking
planning and local tax collection rates
is down although the council is well
placed to respond
the longer term impact is more uncertain
therefore we must continuously adapt and
look for ways to keep vital services
running
this means we need to continue to think
commercially
and look for revenue generating
opportunities
but i must point out that we also need
to ensure public value is the focus
for every commercial decision made we
will continue to question
is this the right thing to do as well as
seek to raise funds from some of
our project and asset projects and
assets
the updated corporate plan we published
in february of this year
clearly sets out the council's
priorities and is consistent with the
statement i made in december of last
year
have become upon becoming the leader the
plan
maintains the three key three key themes
of place
prosperity and community but brings a
greater focus to our activities and
particularly
around the environment the economy and
our work with communities to support the
great work they are doing
looking ahead there are positives to
focus on we're excited about
bringing forward our commitment to
climate action
as many of our councillors and residents
are passionate about the environment
and initiative we can take we are going
to reach out to our young people
and communities to give them the
opportunity to take climate action
and to be part of our our home our
future
engagement group to ensure that they
have an active voice in making long-term
accessible change the title reflects
that this is the strategy to be owned by
us all and it affects
everyone's future we have continued to
support businesses in both surviving the
challenges of the coveted pandemic
through 27 million pounds of grant
direct grant support
whilst also looking forward to the
future and how the economy of the
district can grow
and thrive as restrictions ease we have
introduced initiatives
such as click and collect to help local
retailers to come
compete with online offers to protect
viability sorry the vitality of our high
streets
we are working with partners to deliver
a wide range of business
supporting business support including
business
startup funding and capacity building of
existing businesses work is also
underway on the modern district
investment prospectus
to attract new businesses to locate in
our district
we continue to build on our excellent
partnerships and work within the
community
whilst covered has been and continues to
be a challenge
we have been proud to be part of an
amazing community response
we have seen in the district this
includes the work we have done with the
cvs
the community partners to support the
community hubs
and also the work we have done with the
nhs to provide the vaccine center at the
council offices
a huge thank you to all but everyone for
everything everyone has done no matter
how large
or how small i have no doubt we have
many unsung heroes and heroines within
this room alone
as well as in our wonderful wider
community we continue to work with
partners
and are keen to build on the
partnerships that have been formed
to enhance support our communities and
we hopefully move past this pandemic and
embrace the opportunities
of a new future we will be bringing
forward initiatives to strengthen these
partnerships including the one moldon
district approach
that will be presented to the council
this evening as a model of how we can
capture the benefits of working in
partnership
and achieve more by working together the
other part of our corporate plan
was the introduction of the shared set
of corporate values
signed up by both officers and members
following a year of political turmoil
and unfortunate conflict at the council
this shed this shared set of values
and the buy-in of the whole council is
seen as vital to the ability for the
ability to move forward
together we are a team that has shaped a
new set of core values
that must be embedded to create a
culture of feeling
safe and connected and that helps to
openly and respectfully
challenge issues and ideas we want to
attract talented people to work for the
council
and retain the great staff we have we
also want local people
to want to become elected members of the
council
our time is best spent delivering
services ensuring policies are fit for
purpose
and seeking opportunities for the
district not on efforts that distract us
from what we are here to do
that wastes time and is an attempt at
that waste time or is an attempt at
point scoring
any behaviour that prevents us from
being successful has to be challenged
we won't tolerate any negative behavior
that unfairly or disrespectfully attacks
councillors
staff and the council especially at a
time when the council has been working
in exceptional circumstances and under
immense pressure
other key priorities of the year include
the review of our local development plan
which we will be consulting on later in
the year it is an opportunity to shape
the district
and provide homes and services for local
families
and residents who want to live in the
district and continue to build their
lives here
this review is key to the future of the
district
as we will be asking for your views as
we seek to put in place a plan
that will deliver growth in a
sustainable way
that meets the needs of residents in
terms of homes and economic growth
but also focuses on sustainability
appropriate infrastructure
and the protection of all that is
already great about the unique character
of our district we have put together a
dedicated team to ensure our local
development plan is delivered
effectively
and we have switched resources away from
bradwell b project
as the development programme from brb
has slowed this year
we will re-engage fully in that work in
due course
and as necessary but it is vital that as
a council with relatively limited
resources
we do focus those resources in the areas
where we need to deliver
with that in mind as we seek to deliver
the corporate plan
focusing on those priorities i have
highlighted on those priorities i've
highlighted
as well as a renewed commercial
commercial development to support
financial sustainability i will be
asking our directors to ensure
that the structure and resources we have
in place
are fit for purpose to deliver that
agenda
once we recognize the needs for council
to live within their means we also
recognize that if staff are being asked
to deliver
they need to have the right resources
and we will seek
to ensure those resources are in place
and that our approach
is geared to delivery we are proud of
how we have delivered our services
and additional response that sorry
support for the community
through the challenges of the pandemic
and we are determined that as
we now go forward we continue to deliver
and maintain that momentum to deliver
not
only to the minimum required but
additional services
and support to meet the challenges in
the future i would like to thank all the
members of staff who work
at modern district council for all their
hard work and challenges they have faced
and still face
i would also i also wish to thank the
members of the independent group
for all their hard work commitment trust
heated discussions and believe me
there's been a few
and support not only of me and
councillor none my excellent deputy
but the leadership team and hope we can
continue to work
up with all political parties and groups
in the future
after all working together is far better
for our residents for the reasons i
presented
in in my leaders speech mr chairman i
present this speech to the council
with the sincere belief and
determination to do the right thing from
the malden district
thank you
thank you leader counselor channel
would you like to make a statement
yes would you like to make a response uh
yes i will thank you very much
thank you very much it's a bit daunting
having a mic come around the side of you
uh right can i thank the leader for
letting me having this speech as i
walked into the
well i'll call it the chamber tonight
but thank you very much so i've actually
got a hard copy this time which makes it
a little bit easier
and um i would just say obviously i'll
raise a few points have been raised
obviously i think we all know the
outcome of the
elections and i think it was very fair
elections that were conducted
and obviously we're constituted tonight
and uh pleased to see
two new members who were successful in
the by-elections in the malden district
regarding remembering the residents
business owners friends family and loved
ones i think
everyone in this room can relate to that
and probably every resident can
i think sadly many of us have lost
people we knew
including colleagues friends or family
and i extend the heartfelt sympathies
of the conservative group to everyone
and i'm sure
that's same for the independents and
other people
our other members regarding livelihoods
and health being the main concerns i i
do agree with that
and of course that does include mental
health and i think you did refer to that
and obviously going forward um it is
about supporting residents that have
suffered and businesses and our whole
community
and obviously recognizing as you did
leader the
nhs and also the vaccination program
and the marvellous vaccination
system that was carried out within the
malden district council offices
and i think we all praise the nhs staff
i know
i did and many here probably did joined
in the clapping that was a regular
exercise in the early days
on thursday evenings and i think also
the vaccination program
um is actually showing its success now
and i think the figures that are being
revealed daily
um and people having not only their
single vaccination dose
but second one is highly important to
the health of everyone and hoping
everyone
to somehow beat this virus or lead a
life that we can live
in a way of quality by having the
vaccinations rather than having it
really
dictate to us all the world and i do
believe that from a crisis comes
opportunity
and we do have to have a sense of hope
in the community
and it does come with cautiousness and i
do take that point on board and i think
many
people the great majority of the
community do do that and pay
heed to the restrictions that may be
there or the cautiousness that makes to
be taken going forward
i do agree the longer term impacts on
the pandemic are not fully known yet
and to be frank with you i think
what we can say is there's a number of
things we may know
that there are long-term impacts as well
as short-term
on people's physical and mental health
finances local jobs
businesses and education and some areas
due to inequalities
may have been hit harder so we need to
have ambitions
in in certain areas which is about
driving equality
dampening agreeing recovery creating and
protecting
jobs and supporting businesses which
you've referred to
and promoting health and well-being
protecting the most
vulnerable and we could do this i hope
by some form of public consultation
i do think it's important that the
residents tell us what their fears may
be going forward
so we can get their views on board and
i'm sure we might find that
very interesting madam chairman the
corporate plan
published in february which you relate
to
um and i i've taken note of your last
point on that
um the economy and our work with
communities support the great work
they're doing
the communities are they were a bed drop
during the covid19 pandemic
without the communities helping one
another becoming stronger together
looking after the vulnerable and the
elderly
and anyone who was in need have really i
think shone
high as the stars in the night in the
malden district
and i think what it's shown to me
already there is an inclusivity
and cohesion with our communities but i
do think this council has responded
responsibilities
to sure we actually engender and take
that further
regarding climate action and and as you
know councils and residents are
passionate about this
and i am and the environment and it's
great to see young people being
involved but i think we also need to
lead in that madam chairman bearing in
mind
the annual public sector energy bill is
estimated to be 3.4 billion
with 40 percent of the uk co2 emissions
coming from heat and buildings i'm
talking about the public sector
decarbonizing heat in public buildings
is one of the biggest challenges
facing the uk actually and how does the
public
sector navigate low carbon solutions
to in order to drive energy performance
in
both our new and old buildings i'm
talking about malden district council
here the estate that we have
and i think we need to look at all
opportunities to take positive step
toward towards carbon
net zero and um
regarding council i think it's important
and take on board in order to support
local government in its role
that's our council included of leading
places
and i'm talking about residents and
businesses and providing a greener
future
councils and businesses must continue to
work together
and with government to establish a
framework for addressing climate
emergencies and tackling perhaps
biodiversity loss and i'm glad this
council has agreed
a climate emergency already so i think
that's a very
great positive we've got there um
regarding the modern district investment
prospectus that you spoke to
to attract new business to locate in our
district uh that's very very important
and that has been
raised an element of it at the covid19
reset and recovery working group which
is looking at that
which i sit on and several other members
so that is really a body that is trying
to make sure
that the reset and recovery out of the
pandemic
to assist our businesses and in other
areas uh gives strength back to the
district where it may be weakened by
this pandemic
just going back to the climate change i
think the climate
action working group that's been set up
we the body that can really
look in great detail at all the elements
of our way
forward for this council the district
residents and our young people going
forward
uh regarding initiatives you've
mentioned their
one malden district approach and that's
on the agenda tonight
so i think that should be um quite an
interesting one
excellent partnerships i do agree there
i think
when you made your speech in november i
made that point that i felt
the partnerships that came forward and
have continued well they were there
before they strengthened during the
covered pandemic
i think going forward partnerships will
be
something that we all realize we engage
in because of help with resources
and bringing the sum total together to
really deliver the outcome we all might
be seeking
uh then you did say about the core
values and madam chairman i totally
agree with you on the core values
and i especially like some of your words
there
and sentences about people and what we
won't tolerate
negative behavior that might unfairly or
disrespectfully attack
counsellors staff and counsel especially
when everyone's been working on
exceptional
and under immense pressure and i think
the customer focus core value is the one
that stands out to me that is what we
are all about
customers our residents that is what
we're here for
they are the taxpayer and we've got to
ensure that we work
hard and do the best we can for them
while being respectful to others
and ethically and ethically operating
and with integrity
but also be innovative be ambitious be
open and transparent and i do think we
need to broaden that
quite uh significantly into the future
and be accountable for our actions and
to collaborate
to deliver and so madam chairman i think
who raised
very good point about the core values
which we all have signed up to regarding
the local development plan
again that really is important that
review adopting
the local plan as we did to take us
forward with our housing
as we know now with the reasons for
review and we must carry that forward
and of course which is very important as
well are the two consultations going on
at the moment
which i do hope our community and
residents do respond to
that is the statement of community
involvement and the duty to cooperate
which is vital and uh we need to make
sure
that we do obviously bring forward uh
the best
development plan review that we can to
ensure
that we have everything coming forward
that this district might require
infrastructure wise without actually uh
compromising if you like the beauty of
our district doing it all in the right
way
and putting development or ensuring put
development in the right place
regarding bradwell which you've
highlighted that is a very very
significant
thing on everyone's agenda i'm a dengue
councillor
i'm sure and you are madame uh madam
leader too so i might have said i'm
madam chairman
i think i don't think you are but the
leader is and i think the leader will
know as others in this chamber do
uh being dengue councillors how
important it is to our residents to
keep abreast of all developments might
might be coming forward
and i think it's absolutely essential
that even though the bradwell b
project might have if you like got a
hiatus and we're directing the resources
elsewhere
i do feel all members in this chamber
but more pertinently perhaps those in
the dingy hun
uh denji hundred who represent residents
need to be kept informed of any
developments whatsoever
so that we hear it first from within our
council
and not perhaps from other sources or
read things in the malden and burnham
because um and the community forum which
is still ongoing
actually is one of those bodies which to
a degree is keeping
one informed but i'm not sure that the
uh
the news from that necessarily filters
out wide and far in all directions
regarding the staff and the members of
staff
i won't say the members at this point as
i said last time in november madam
chairman in response to your statement
what i would like to offer now is my
profuse thanks to all of them
i think i said then i felt they were all
committed dedicated and holy
professional
throughout this whole pandemic without
the staff operating in the manner they
have
i don't think we would have been able to
keep the level of services that we have
yes there may have been hiccups yes
there may have been
challenges but actually what came
forward was innovative thinking
what came forward was energy what came
forward
was responsibilities and accountability
and with the sole purpose of recognizing
what we needed to provide to our
residents in a time
of great need and comp and challenge and
i do thank all the staff for every
effort they have put forward by doing
that
i do agree that we all need to work
together
you know that i do believe in that
however and you did mention challenge
yourself
and about being sensible challenge
another challenge we do need to have
challenge
in the chamber we may not all have the
same view it's important we are able to
have that discussion within this chamber
have our views and have votes if needs
be
it's not necessarily always political
it's because we do
always work with the best intentions for
the district
and we may have differences on that but
challenge is important
democracy is important and if we don't
have that then we won't need this
council chamber
and sadly we won't need councillors to
look after
and represent the views of the residents
and support them
and be there we are actually the link to
the authority
of the residents of this district and
i believe they need a quality of life
and i believe working together
and having all those things that might
be mentioned your statement and those i
have madam chairman
i do believe we will go forward stronger
together and this district
this council the members and the
residents will come out
stronger for it by working together we
will achieve where we want to be
adam sherman i firmly believe that and
leader thank you
thank you uh counselor channel leader do
you wish to respond
um no i just yes
yes i know yes briefly thank you
councillor chana
um excellent response thank you very
much i agree with everything you've said
it is a democracy
and it is a good job we are here because
we have to keep the officers in check
um so so thank you very much
and i think we'll move on madam chair
thank you thank you leader
um item ten uh questions in accordance
with procedure rule
six three of which notice has been given
there are none
item 11 uh we moved to this
item found on pages 47 to 52
the making of the wickham bishops
neighborhood plan
leader thank you madam chair um
members this is a this is brilliant we
all like neighbourhood plans coming to
the final stage a lot of hard work no
doubt has gone on
through the process because we all know
how long it can take
um i don't think i need to dwell on and
keep us all here for longer than we need
to the recommendation is quite
straightforward
that the council makes the wiccan bishop
neighborhood plan in accordance with
section 38
a 4 of the planning and compulsory
purchase act 2004.
um do you want me to refer to the
officers does any officers want to speak
or can we just go for no officers want
to speak thank you
and can i propose it do i have a
secondary please counseling
do we all agree by ascent thank you and
well done we should
we can bishops yeah well done
item 12 one malden district
um these can be found on pages 53 to 62
and the report on one moldon district
and the recommendations
leader yes um thank you madam chair
this is obviously i refer to in in my
speech
i hope you all enjoyed it it was a
little bit dry wasn't it the speech
members i didn't put any jokes in but
you all know i'm not the funniest person
in the world
um the recommendation is that we the
council endorses
uh the approach for the formation of one
moulding district
omd and the merging and strategic arm of
the
livewell group and responsible
authorities group to omd
enabling a joint joined up approach to
community safety
and health and well-being i've read that
recommendation out first
do i have a seconder
counselor none okay i'd like to move
that before if that was all right with
you madam chair yes before the debate
i'm going to go
to mr dodson who because i would think
members
may have some points um to ask mr dodson
mr dawson can you present
um the report please thank you
um health and wellbeing and community
safety are key elements of the molden
district council corporate plan
and this report promotes the systems
management approach to improving
outcomes regarding those issues
the proposals for one modern district
have been presented to cancel previously
at the beginning of 2020
since then we've obviously been subject
to the covid pandemic
which has further highlighted the need
for close working with partners
in a systems management approach to
health and well-being
systems management is a recognition that
issues in this case relating to health
and well-being and community safety
do not exist in isolation they result of
a number of factors
it's also a recognition as a council we
do not control all of those factors and
we therefore need to work closely with
partners to resolve those issues
and create the best outcomes for the
residents of the district
the council's committed to an
evidence-based approach to policy
and this report references the robert
woods johnson model of health
determinants
which highlights the links between
health behaviors
socioeconomic factors clinical care
and built environment as the key
determinants of a healthy population
there's also evidence that similar
socioeconomic factors
influence crime and community safety
in accepting the evidence behind these
arguments it would seem a logical
next step to bring together key partners
across the district
into a single group to consider the
evidence and how we can
through our collective resources and
responsibilities bring about the best
conditions
to improve health and well-being and
community safety
that in essence is what one modern
district is proposing through the
merging of the livewell partnership and
the responsible authorities group that
deals with community safety
into one group one modern district
the proposal would enable partners to
work together most effectively to
address the issues of health and
well-being and community safety
and look at how we manage systemic
challenges
the report highlights that the approach
of merging these groups is not new
and is again based on best practice in
other areas including our near
neighbours
in chelmsford colchester and braintree
who all operate a similar model
further details are shown in appendix
one of how the model would work
including the introduction of subgroups
to ensure that the voice of smaller
groups is still heard
and that we do not lose the detail and
local approach in drawing these groups
together
thank you chairman thank you um i'll now
open the floor to debate does anybody
wish to speak
uh councillor swain and then councillor
white and cancer china
and then consultant yeah just said that
i need this for the benefit of the
microphone
and thank you madam chairman um thank
you councillor channel
um yes i have a few points um i
do um have concerns when we get involved
in a lot of this
theoretical management and
organizational um
uh uh language um and uh
i think it what we have to guard against
here is
i agree with merging the internal groups
that's fair enough
but it's regarding the mid essex
alliance
um we are in danger of creating a more
bureaucratic um arrangement um
and i think we need to bear in mind
perhaps the
um example we've seen with covered
in the different performance of
the vaccine
out on the one hand and the test and
trace on the other
the vaccine rollout has been a success
because it's been involving a lot of
local
activity local voluntary groups and so
on
um the test and trace on your hand other
hand
is an example of something top-down very
bureaucratic
which hasn't actually delivered because
the
the actual delivery system for what it's
trying to do
hasn't been there um
so i think we would have to guard
against some
an arrangement that somehow it inhibits
or restricts
the work of individual local community
organizations
in the interests of some sort of
coordinated
priorities
as far as mid-essex concerned i i know
this is the way the health authorities
are organized
so we may we have to go along with that
but personally i don't think it's a
coherent
area and even if you add on then south
essex
eventually i don't think that's really
coherent either
it really has to be on an essex basis
i think um last two other minor points
um first of all um how do we
how are we going to judge that this
whole effort is going to contribute
anything worthwhile
to the over and above the present
situation
and lastly what on earth is an asset
based community development model
thank you
sorry mr dodson could you take that last
question um on an asset model
certainly an asset-based community
development model
is a model in which it works directly
with communities and most primarily
with the residents the residents are the
assets
to which it refers and it's ensuring
that
communities and and the the people of
those communities
are heavily involved in the development
of the the policies
that support their communities and that
we co-produce and work with them
to to develop the ideas and the programs
that support them
thank you uh
councillor white
um now i i have big concerns over this
i've sat on both committees
and um i don't believe there's any way
they can be merged
and something that um mr dodson said
that we wouldn't lose the detail i
believe that we will absolutely lose the
detail
um on rag the responsible authorities
group there's only one molded district
council
member and for years i was the only
member president it was all
officer-led it was all very detailed and
it was all relevant down to the district
um and i used to send memorandums around
to all
members to let them know what was going
on and it was really important that this
detail is kept and member involvement
now with the live well it's already too
big for malden district council officers
and we've had to hire the hall in malden
for a full day
meeting and we only had small amounts of
the partnership members there it's a
huge huge um operation
and i think that we're going to lose the
member involvement
if it's all merged together i mean
either again against all these big
mergers anyway i think we need to keep
morton district
for the mulder members and for the
malden residents
after all it's what we are elected for
and it's what's important to us
and to our residents we need to be able
to have the involvement and detail
for our members i've also been down the
tour which the terms of reference and
the mou
it's the memorandum of understanding and
it's not clear on representation of how
many members are going to be present
how is it split how is it going to be
chosen
regardless of political parties splits
or control we need to be certain
and in my mind because these issues this
needs to be deferred until there's more
clarity
this is a huge decision and we must work
for our members and i know that all the
members in this area
worry about their members and want to
have a major understanding so
i don't have anyone to help me with the
tour and the mou on
member involvement because it isn't
clear i mean maybe i've missed something
but it is absolutely not clear
thank you madam chairman thank you um mr
dodson
can you help us on um the terms of
reference in the mou
yes thank you chairman the terms of
reference provided um
sets out the the broad structures it
does say within the report
that this is to to approve the principle
of the approach
and we would be coming back to finalize
the appointment of members
to the the group madam chair can i help
there just say on the conclusion 4.1
on the report the information is is
there thank you
thank you leader um thank you
um can i move to uh councillor chana
please
thank you madam chairman um yes
councillor white actually has
touched on a number of things that i was
going to be saying
and i my one concern is um
to a degree well not only concern is
that to me it does
actually seem to have a lack of there's
a deficit in
democratic accountability from alden
district there regarding
what appears to be very limited member
inclusion
i appreciate what you've highlighted
leader and i appreciate what mr dodson
has
about there's going to be a a following
report
which will determine the final structure
initially proposed
and uh also about member involvement is
that mdc members
and the reason i say that because
actually the recommendation when you
read the report
you don't necessarily see everything
within the text of the report
reflected in the recommendation the
recommendation is going to say
council endorses the approach to the
formation of this one malden district
emerging strategic arm of the live well
group and responsible authorities group
enabling a joined up approach so it
could all be geared and go ahead
nowhere does it say about for a
following report
and about member inclusion and subgroups
and nowhere actually does it say this is
only an in principle
it does not say that in principle we
agree to this and
following reports come back to this
council with all the detail
which members i do believe sought i
believe there was an earlier report
actually which was
actually not agreed this has come back
again and i don't think it's in the
finished
form yet and that's no disrespect to mr
dodson i think he might have an
indication of my views anyway
but i think it's very important that
something important as this
does get actually worked out right and
if we do look at the terms of reference
it says they're a draft
however there do seem to be a lot of
bodies shown in the flow diagram
are they the proposals of the subgroups
or are there other subgroups or is that
the structure that is being set up
and also it is really the essex health
and wellbeing board
and i noticed a number of those groups
and i was an essex county councillor so
this is nothing against essex county
council
but a number of those bodies i've worked
on actually
and they are essex county council bodies
and that's
we need to work with essex county
council i understand that and then we go
down to the live well groups that sort
of the bottom tier
so is that where mr dodson might be
thinking that members of mdc
sit or will they we will have that
inclusivity
if they are the subgroups on those uh
the malden's children advisory board the
community safety partnership
and an indication of numbers and
councillor white's right we had
about there were six members i think on
the live well group and others could
attend
so i've sort of given an idea i want to
know what the subgroups are
is this flow diagram reflective of it
has this
document been anywhere else have other
bodies mentioned had a look at this
is this a document with terms of
reference that requires to go all
through the bodies that will be forming
this one molden
and if so uh because obviously i'm i'm
sure they have a process like us
where you have to have your governance
to ensure everyone's happy what you're
signing up to
has that process started at all yet or
is this purely coming to us first
to seek this way forward before it goes
anywhere else thank you madam chairman
uh thank you councillor uh chana um mr
dodson can you
um just go through this uh i think it's
figure two
uh in the report um and actually outline
how
how the subgroups will be made up and
how
member input will actually occur
yes thank you chairman yes this is the
proposal of the
the subgroups but at the moment it
obviously is a proposal and it's what's
been worked up to date
um in terms of engagement this was taken
through
the the livewell partnership and the
little board previously
to highlight the the opportunities
around here and the potential subgroups
and that was done
last january um ahead of the the
pandemic
we've not had the opportunity to take it
back
since the pandemic and to go through it
again in in any level of detail with the
partners
which again is why i think it's
important as i said in the introduction
that
whilst the pandemic and the working with
communities and with partners has
demonstrated
the need for systems management and for
us to work together more closely
we need to go through that final
iteration to finally
to finalize the detail and make sure
that we're able to
um amongst other things finalize which
groups members will sit on it's
obviously not for officers to reduce the
representation of members on there
we just need to make sure that the
representation it's clear
how that relates to the group to ensure
that there's the the democratic mandate
within the process
thank you thank you um councillor jana
does that answer your question
uh mr dodson just referred about the
member obviously
inclusion so therefore my question is
really what
if you like what influence does this
council have
over that to ensure there's more
representation
democratic accountability and
involvement
in in this body or the subgroups going
forward bearing in mind it's called one
moldon
the proposals are for for members to
put a member representation to to be on
that group and to ensure that there's
the the same level of democratic
um involvement that there is presently
okay thank you very much um
can i now move to uh councillor mrs
stilts
thank you council thompson
um a question for mr dobson really under
3.6 next steps
you talk about the um structure being
uh proposed initial proposed to be the
leader and the count
and the chairman of strategy and
resources but then under 5.1 you talk
about
the focus on performance and values why
is the chair or the vice chair of
performance governance and
it not on this group
thank you thank you uh mr dodson
it's the the
the proposal was was done that way
because it was
it's strategy based group the the
performance and value
obviously pga holds um
groups to account and looks at the the
performance but that would be done
through that committee rather than
through representation
directly on the group giving that
independence to have that overview of it
and for the
um information to feedback via the
committee
thank you thank you um
councillor siddall
over here thank you
thank you madam chairman dave if we look
at the recommendation the recommendation
is that the council endorses the
approach
to the formation of one moldon district
council so this will come back it's
implied in that recommendation that this
is the starting point
and if we don't start it it won't ever
finish
and we'll be going round and round in
circles like this forever
so we do need to start this process the
whole thing about
covid and what we've learned over the
last year in in code
is this is all about coordination it's
all those things we've learned about
clovid
which which will help the district the
interesting thing is
it's not called one moldon district
council
it's called one moulding so therefore
it's got to have a wide representation
and we don't want a load of members
hogging that
that committee it's got to be the right
representation and i'm sure mr dobson
will ensure
that there is the right representation
at the strategic
and that's the key thing about this it's
a strategic
body and then the other working groups
will have the necessary representation
that still exists and that's the
important thing to remember it's not
taking things away
it's actually giving us more and that's
what we've got to recognize
we're getting more and we're having
something which is going to have a
joined up approach for malden
and it's going to make sense for malden
as it can ensure that we as malden
district council have a strong
recommendation
representation on those health
committees
so we will still get that same
representation
it's about strategy it's about
coordination all those things we've
learned about covid
we're now trying to put into practice by
the creation and the formation
of one molded district a strategic
arm that's the crucial thing so this is
the starting point
we need to start it if we keep going
around in circles
it will never get done thank you
thank you councillor councillor thompson
and then councillor hobner
slightly different direction my question
is um will this body be taking over the
direct discussions that mdc's had with
the
department of health or the national
health about the health
hub or community hospital
and one other thing is will the
performance of this body need to be
monitored uh will it help
deliver our corporate planned policies
it certainly seems to
but how will that be measured please so
that's a good question
oh yeah thank you uh councillor thompson
i think
a pg a were actually going to monitor it
but the discussions regarding the health
hub mr um
dalton are you able to enlighten us
thank you chairman no this wouldn't
replace our direct discuss
discussions with the nhs around the the
health hub
though those would continue through the
modern operational group as they as they
do now which we're represented on
directly
uh and i'm um assuming that i was
writing
in saying that it would be monitored
through yes
okay thank you uh finally um
councillor hovener
thank you chair there's obviously been a
lot of concern over this
uh this evening and one of the problems
i've got
is really that you've mentioned that
uh really we're gonna have difficulty
understanding this
so how does the public feel about not
understanding something that the council
publishes
and if we're having difficulty with it
what the public going to say about it
that's my main concern because we are
the link to the public
and we are meant to represent them
they start asking us questions about
this how are we going to answer them
thank you um i think we've uh oh
sorry uh councillor bell
thank you um madam chair i think
councillor houdini's doing the
general public rather a disservice there
that's my personal view
i just want to say we all know the
limitations of silo working
we all know the positives have joined up
working this looks like an excellent
opportunity i think we should grab it
with both hands
thank you thank you councillor bill um i
now move to
the vote oh mr uh sorry councillor
um beale
that we had here i did ask about
southminster medical center
and in fact the record states that the
nhs
progress on plans for the delivery of a
medical center at southminster would be
circulated to dengue members
in the next couple of weeks that hasn't
happened i'm not um
complaining about the district officer
but i do think that was not strong
enough
over the years i've seen these sort of
things identified
and then after a couple of months it's
been forgotten
until it's uh re uh instated again so i
think that what was stated there
needs a lot more strength in in respect
of um
its intent uh where it says that members
of
ng100 or dungy members will be told
contacted in the next couple of weeks
that hasn't happened could i ask that we
have
an agenda item which says southminster
medical center so it's not forgotten and
in fact as progress
is made it will then be reported back to
members
as expected but it will not be lost off
the tracking
system and i don't think to say
that they'll be circulated in next
couple of weeks officers are overworked
at the moment
and so i think that we ought to have as
an agenda item
to update all members
thank you uh councillor chana
do you want
actually if i may madam chairman i think
i'm entitled to if i may
my proposal would be bearing in mind
hinging on my first
opening words i think the trouble here
is the report
is written one and this is no disrespect
to mr dodson the reporters were
worded in a certain way that makes you
think this isn't the final
pudding or recipe if you like um
but that actually the recommendation and
i do disagree
uh with all due respect to councillor
siddal to a degree
i appreciate this is more and yes in my
response to the leader i think i said i
highlighted all the issues i felt
covered had impacted on and i do see the
merits in perhaps
as i said partnership working and
working together
i think what's causing members some of
discomfort is
the structure may be so therefore madam
chairman i said i don't think the report
was reflected well within the
recommendation of whether the
recommendation really didn't reflect
what was in the report so therefore
perhaps it could be that the council
in principle in principle uh
endorses the approach to the formation
of uh the one malden district
and the merging of the strategic arm of
the live well group and responsible
authorities group
blah blah blah but a follow a further
report
needs to come back to this council with
further details
to enable it to determine the final
structure
and member inclusion and the um
to debate and to agree
the final terms of reference
i think that may assist the situation i
don't know if that will be seconded
though
um councillor chana is that um
another motion or is that a an amendment
okay we have to take the first proposal
first that is on the table which has
already been
you're in the chair um i don't want to
say about the um standing orders to you
but or
um amendment if you want to take it as
an amendment
so that if the leader moved a proposal i
think it might have to be an amendment
it doesn't negate the um the proposal on
the table
i'll leave it in your hands when i'm
chairman i don't want to be out here
please uh
um councillor chana can actually make an
amendment i think her amendment would be
if one follows the wording of the
recommendation at our agenda item 12
it would read that the council endorses
in principle the word in principle added
in
the approach to the formation of one
molten district
and merging the strategy arm of the uh
the live well group and the responsible
authorities group into
omd enabling a joined up approach to
community safety health and well-being
subject to a further report to council
yes subject to a referred report and and
then i'm not sure
i can't quite remember the detail you
mentioned sorry
and also the member inclusion and also
to agree the um final terms of reference
um i think members need to have that
detail and assurances before
probably everyone feels happy listening
to comments vote made by
all parties in the chamber so i'm just
trying to move this forward
i think that is a good compromise to get
this going forward but equally
give members the surety and security
they need to have
okay thank you uh councillor channel um
we need to vote on the amendment
first um and uh then we'll come back to
the
the substantive uh so um
uh yeah i did see sorry i beg your
pardon i i did see you
uh councillor thompson uh council
thompson has seconded the motion uh
sorry the amendment
um are we uh can we take a vote
now please um with a show of hands all
those
thank you tara could we take a recorded
vote by member please
oh
[Music]
[Music]
mr stilts councillor swain
councillor mrs thompson councillor miss
white
thank you chairman uh very no sorry i've
got to count it's not
that's 10 4.
twelve against and two abstentions
chairman
uh thank you miss bird um the amendment
has fallen uh i now would like to take
you to the vote
on uh the substantive motion as as
originally
written do i have
thank you
miss bird could we take another recorded
vote please
going back to the uh motion as set out
on the papers
if you could just indicate four against
or extend
please want to call your name starting
with councillor bassinger please
thank you councillor miss beale
councillor brian beale councillor bell
councillor mrs channer
thank you counselor durham councillor
edwards
councillor huberner
councillor hull councillor jarvis
councillor keys councillor lagan
councillor mays for councillor morley
councillor morris councillor none
councillor mrs shaughnessy councillor
siddall
councillor stamp councillor stevens
councillor mrs stiltz councillor swain
council mrs thompson
councillor miss white chairman the
results of that are 14
4 4 against and six abstentions thank
you
the recommendation is carried can we now
move on to item
13 the mid essex alliance memorandum of
understanding
on pages 63 to 82
leader yes thank you madam chair
um it's um quite straightforward i don't
think i need to go through the report
members unless you'd like me to
the recommendation is that the council
agrees to be a signatory
to the mid essex alliance memorandum of
understanding i think it's really just
for
nothing i propose
that we adapt we agree the
recommendation do i have a second
counseling none all those in favor
there's a little paragraph
two-line paragraph saying whilst health
services form a significant part of the
public sector in mid-essex
it is the social determinants of health
which have the greatest impact on the
health and well-being of its residents
i would disagree i think what what we
need
is uh decent health facilities and which
are accessible to the residents of
the district and and uh that should be
um a high priority for uh all our policy
initiatives and initiatives with
um partner organizations particularly
the nhs
it's accessible facilities which are
more
are key to the general state of health
and well-being
thank you um councillor morris
cheers thank you madam chairman i was
just um
gonna ask at 3.2
uh it says working with communities and
partners to improve the mental health
and well-being
of our residents how are we doing that
by perpetuating
the fear and scare-mongering surrounding
the coveted pandemic
that is a question for government um
and we are doing everything that we can
i believe um thank you
sorry i don't think what's going on uh
councillor durham
oh yeah yeah councillor daryl
yeah thank you uh thank you chairman
just in response to
councillor swain's uh point um i i i
totally take on board what he's saying
that
um the the actual health facilities are
extremely important but what it says is
whilst health services form a
significant part actually the most
significant
factor affecting health and well-being
of residents
is good housing that is recognized as
being the biggest determinant
for for the health of of residents so
yes i'm not saying that
having medical facilities isn't
important but
for good housing is actually the major
factor
thank you thank you councillor durham
um sorry cat
counselor chat channel sorry i couldn't
quite see your
i'll see you imagine chairman yeah
councillor i've got a short body but my
arm's not long enough either
yes i'm not saying i don't agree with
the recommendation but i do have some
concerns
and this is regarding obviously it's
another change in the structure the nhs
seems to be leading this clinical
commissioning groups go and i'm not
saying against the principles of what
they might be trying to do
however in the report it did say it's
not a decision-making body
that this really was a memorandum of
understanding
but however then when i read the terms
of reference or appendix one
if we go to page 75
in paragraph two it
replays the mid-essex alliance is
expected to make decisions by agreement
of all partners
so there is some decision making going
on and so i wonder if mr
dodson could explain that a bit further
because the report says not decision
making
but clearly it is and then also there's
an area in here
where it also talks about money's and
sort of
funding i think it seems to be there's
some funding elements and yet the report
under the implications says there's no
drain on our resources and no funding
issues well i read something and i can't
now find it
but it's to do with those areas that are
reserved to the modest alliance
and that is about funding or resources
and
that's if partners can't agree so that
therefore did concern me
and also the report i think said this is
not legally binding
however there were some certain things
in there talking about i think
commercial
issues possibly it did seem to relate to
um and other matters i'm now trying to
find it um
and uh there's confidentiality that's
right it came out of confidentiality and
conflicts of interest which started i
think on page 78.
and therefore i could i please ask has
this mou been looked at by our legal
department
because actually i do think we need to
be clear if there's anything there in
there which we need to have alerted to
that might have a legal
uh leaning or inference and therefore i
would like to know
madam chairman has been through our
legal department and looked at and
signed off by them
and that's my cause for concern thank
you thank you
can i take the first question which was
about
the partners all voting and agreeing and
making decisions
um which was the um
page 75 um the paragraph two which was
the mid-essex alliance is expected to
make decisions
um how it is it's a decision-making body
um
yeah thank you yes i agree when
rereading the port i noted that i'd said
that the group's not decision making and
what i had in mind with
in saying that is that it will not make
strategic decisions affecting this
council while the group will make some
decisions
these are largely in relation to
coordination of existing resources
and the the funding that was referred to
is that the nhs has
delegated some responsibility to the
group but what they're not asking for
is for this council or any of the other
partners
to delegate any responsibility to that
that group
any any decisions that are made are
about the the coordination of existing
resources
um in line with any decisions that have
been made by this
council in in terms of our involvement
in that
hence that that was the the term i was
i was referring to and um the
decision-making of the group is
subservient to council and the group is
accountable to council
um and in the case that there any issues
that arise that would materially affect
council policy or resource then these
would
be referred back to council before it
was agreed
just as this mou is being considered by
council
thank you and and answer i it has been
um through the the legal department
and mr quelch has has reviewed it which
i'm
sure he can confirm thank you and there
are no
um concerns that that you've identified
in that uh
document mr welch
is called a memorandum of understanding
and everybody in the public sector knows
what that means
and in that memorandum of understanding
it quite clearly states it's not
creating legal relations
memorandums of understanding are exactly
that they set parameters
between public sector bodies that give
an understanding
and informal understanding how things
are going to work
if for some reason or other this council
doesn't comply with some of those
requirements there are no legal
implications
it doesn't it doesn't make for a binding
agreement it says that itself
and that's the really important point
madam chairman
thank you um can we move to the vote
now um are you happy to agree this by
ascent
or do you agree
can i take a recorded vote um
do i have a second uh
i don't think you can second yourself
can you
yes i think we do
sorry where did virtual meetings come
from
can i can we have a recorded vote please
voting for the recommendation as set out
in the report
starting with councillor bassinger
please
thank you councillor miss beale
councillor brian beale councillor bell
councillor mrs channer councillor durham
councillor edwards councillor hubena
councillor hung councillor jarvis
councillor councillor lagan
councillor mays for councillor morley
councillor morris councillor nunn
councillor shaughnessy councillor siddle
councillor stamp councillor stevens
councillor mrs stilts councillor swain
that's mrs thompson councillor miss
white
thank you very much the chairman the
results of that are 22 4
1 against on one abstention thank you
uh thank you um the recommendation is
carried thank you
um moving on to item 14 are any other
items of business for the the chairman
i have none uh we now move to exclusion
of the press
and public uh i moved to item 15 and to
resolve it under section 100
a subsection 4 of the local government
act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in in paragraph
six of the part of part one of schedule
12 a
to the act and that this satisfies the
public interest
test do i have a seconder thank you
councillor nunn
thank you